halo nama aku Olivia Lan dan aku adalah peneliti dan pengajar di IBM Quantum, video ini menandai peluncuran sebuah
seri baru di channel YouTube Qiskit dan platform belajar kita yang disebut Quantum Computing in
Practice, singkatnya dalam seri ini aku akan menunjukkan cara menggunakan komputer kuantum yang ada sekarang dengan
potensi penuhnya, sudah ada miliaran video di internet tentang komputer kuantum dan potensi masa depannya atau tentang konsep teoritis
di balik komputasi Quantum yang juga sama pentingnya, lihat understanding Quantum information and computation
yang dibawakan oleh John Watrous misalnya, tapi dalam kursus ini kita akan mengasumsikan pelajar mungkin tahu sedikit lebih banyak
dari yang kita miliki di masa lalu dan kita akan pergi sangat jauh secara teknis dan itu karena selama setahun terakhir dan pada
saat perekaman ini adalah 2024, kita telah melihat pergeseran, transisi fase jika kamu mau, ke era baru
komputasi, komputer kuantum akhirnya mendekati titik di mana mereka bisa berguna meskipun bereksperimen dengan
circuit kecil dan komputer kuantum diperlukan untuk mendidik komunitas kita tentang cara memanfaatkan mesin-mesin ini, tidak ada yang menjalankan eksperimen
yang juga tidak bisa dilakukan pada komputer klasik biasa, tapi pada hari ini kita telah memasuki era
quantum utility dan apa itu utility mungkin kamu bertanya? itu berbeda dari Quantum Advantage yang bisa dipahami pada
titik di mana komputer kuantum mengungguli komputer klasik pada tugas yang bermakna, sebaliknya utility berarti
mereka bisa mulai bersaing satu sama lain dan ini adalah langkah alami berikutnya dalam evolusi
teknologi, IBM menerbitkan paper yang menunjukkan untuk pertama kalinya tahun lalu bahwa komputer kuantum bisa digunakan untuk
mensimulasikan model fisik dan bersaing dengan teknik simulasi klasik mutakhir, itu bahkan mengalahkan
upaya Brute Force dan memberi para peneliti jalur baru yang bisa mereka gunakan untuk penelitian, jadi mengapa ini semua terjadi
sekarang? well dalam beberapa bulan terakhir IBM telah membuat prosesor Quantum lebih dari 100 qubit tersedia secara luas, kalau kamu
sudah pengguna kamu mungkin sudah memperhatikan bahwa kita menurunkan banyak prosesor lebih kecil kita untuk memberi jalan bagi chip yang lebih besar ini dan kita rasa sangat
penting untuk melakukannya karena sejumlah qubit masih bisa disimulasikan secara klasik tanpa masalah jadi tidak ada
keunggulan nyata yang bisa diperoleh dengan menggunakan chip-chip ini, namun pada 100 qubit ini bukan lagi masalahnya, mereka tidak bisa
disimulasikan secara klasik, juga penting untuk dicatat bahwa ada hal-hal yang disebut simulator yang
pada dasarnya adalah program komputer dan mereka bisa meniru beberapa perilaku sistem kuantum termasuk noise, namun tolong
jangan lewatkan fakta bahwa aku bilang meniru, simulator bukan komputer kuantum, mereka tidak bisa menghasilkan hasil yang
bisa dihasilkan komputer kuantum pada skala ini tapi mereka tetap merupakan bagian penting dari workflow pengujian kita, jadi itu adalah jawaban yang sangat
panjang untuk pertanyaan di atas slide ini, apa itu Quantum Computing praktis? dalam kursus ini aku akan mengajarkan kamu tentang
kasus penggunaan yang berpotensi realistis untuk Quantum dan praktik terbaik untuk menjalankan dan bereksperimen pada prosesor
yang lebih besar ini hari ini, jadi siapa target kursus ini? mari kita mulai dengan melakukan beberapa level setting
di awal, kursus ini adalah untuk semua orang yang bertujuan mengembangkan aplikasi baru untuk komputer kuantum, ingin
tahu cara scale up pekerjaan mereka saat ini atau belajar cara menggunakan kuantum dalam workflow yang sudah ada, aku sebelumnya
menyebutkan bahwa kursus ini akan sangat hands-on dan kita tidak akan membahas aspek teoritis hampir sama banyaknya, kita
mengharapkan kamu datang dengan pemahaman dasar tentang apa itu komputasi Quantum tapi kalau kamu belum sampai di sana belum, tidak masalah silakan saja tonton
beberapa episode pertama dari kursus John Watrous dan kamu akan siap, kita juga ingin memastikan bahwa orang-orang yang menonton tahu
bahwa ini bukan hanya kursus untuk fisikawan atau bahkan ilmuwan komputer, dua subjek ini memang sudah
mendominasi Quantum Computing selama sekitar satu dekade terakhir, kita ingin memastikan bahwa orang lain yang bekerja dengan big data atau
simulasi seperti insinyur, kimiawan dan ilmuwan material tahu bahwa kursus ini juga untuk mereka, singkatnya
kursus ini ditujukan untuk khalayak luas dan kita berharap kamu akan bergabung dengan kita untuk keseluruhannya, setelah menyelesaikan kursus ini kamu
akan bisa memahami cara membuat dan menjalankan pekerjaan skala utilitas melalui Qiskit runtime termasuk seluruh workflow
kamu akan bisa memahami jenis utama dari error mitigation dan juga memahami area aplikasi yang mungkin dalam jangka pendek, kamu juga akan bisa
melakukan semua algoritma ini di Qiskit dan terakhir kita mengharapkan kamu bisa memahami noise dan cara mengatasinya
jadi mari mulai, Quantum Computing adalah teknologi baru yang menarik dalam tahap awal pengembangan tapi ini hanyalah
satu bab dalam kisah komputasi yang sudah berlangsung ribuan tahun, aku pikir penting untuk memahami
konteks ini karena membuat apa yang kita targetkan di sini sedikit lebih intuitif, dapat diprediksi dan kurang
fiksi ilmiah, sejak zaman kuno kita sebagai manusia perlu melakukan komputasi atau
dengan kata lain memproses informasi sesuai dengan aturan dan batasan tertentu untuk memungkinkan
komunikasi, konstruksi, perdagangan, ilmu pengetahuan dan semua aspek kehidupan kita lainnya, kita telah mencari bantuan ke dunia fisik
dan melalui penemuan-penemuan yang brilian kita telah membangun perangkat untuk membantu kita menghitung, sudah lama perangkat dibuat
dari kayu, tulang, tali yang disimpul dan mereka menyimpan informasi dan memfasilitasi perhitungan dengan cara yang sangat berbeda dari yang kita lakukan
sekarang, perangkat mekanik yang dibangun dari tuas, roda gigi dan mesin lainnya berkembang dari jam astronomi awal ke
kalkulator ke perangkat komputasi canggih seperti differential analyzer yang memecahkan persamaan menggunakan roda dan
disk yang berputar, bahkan teknologi penulisan telah memainkan peran penting dalam cerita ini dengan memungkinkan orang melakukan
komputasi yang tidak akan bisa mereka lakukan sebaliknya, ketika kita berpikir tentang komputer hari ini kita cenderung berpikir tentang
komputer digital elektronik tapi ini sebenarnya teknologi yang cukup baru, komputer digital elektronik
pertama kali dibangun pada tahun 1940-an, alat yang paling awal diketahui sebenarnya untuk komputasi adalah Sempoa Sumeria
yang menurut para ahli ditemukan di Babilonia pada 2700 hingga 2300 SM, itu sudah sangat
lama tapi kita telah memahami semakin banyak tentang alam dari Archimedes ke Euclid ke
Einstein, kebutuhan kita akan sumber daya komputasi yang lebih besar telah meledak, hari ini kita memiliki superkomputer yang pada dasarnya
adalah banyak komputer yang sangat kuat terhubung secara paralel, mereka adalah salah satu alat terbaik yang dimiliki umat manusia untuk
menyelesaikan masalah yang sulit tapi masih banyak masalah yang bahkan komputer-komputer raksasa ini tidak akan pernah bisa
selesaikan, lebih lanjut tentang ini nanti, jadi kita sudah menetapkan bahwa manusia telah menggunakan fisika dan alam untuk membantu kita menghitung
selama ribuan tahun dan untuk membantu kita dalam pencarian tak berujung untuk menghitung hal-hal yang lebih besar dan lebih besar kamu mungkin sudah
WEBVTT
familiar dengan Hukum Moore, sebenarnya bukan hukum sih, lebih merupakan sebuah observasi, bagian hukumnya menurut aku agak
bercanda, jumlah maksimum transistor dalam sirkuit terpadu pada dasarnya sebuah chip komputer
berlipat ganda sekitar setiap 2 tahun, selama sekitar 5 dekade terakhir kita tidak hanya mengamati ini tapi juga memanfaatkannya
dengan baik, dengan lebih banyak transistor kita bisa melakukan komputasi yang lebih cepat dan lebih banyak, ini pada dasarnya yang bertanggung jawab untuk
membuat komputer semakin kuat dan lebih kecil dari waktu ke waktu, namun ada kabar buruknya, Hukum Moore sedang sekarat
para ahli tidak sepakat tentang kapan Hukum Moore akan mencapai akhirnya yang pasti tapi beberapa mengatakan itu sudah terjadi, meskipun kita mungkin tidak
tahu persis kapan kita akan mencapai batasnya, kita tahu bahwa itu pada akhirnya tak terhindarkan karena beberapa bagian transistor
secara fisik tidak bisa dibuat lebih kecil lagi, kamu tidak bisa membuat transistor yang lebih kecil dari atom misalnya, ini
tentu saja sepenuhnya tidak fisik, terdengar konyol tapi itulah batas yang sebenarnya kita hadapi, jadi apa
yang akan kita lakukan? hanya menyerah dan bilang hey, seperti inilah keadaan terbaiknya? tidak, manusia tidak pernah melakukan itu, untungnya mekanika
kuantum telah masuk dalam percakapan, mekanika kuantum ditemukan pada tahun 1920-an dan sejak itu dunia
secara harfiah tidak pernah sama lagi dan kita bisa menghabiskan berjam-jam membicarakan penemuan-penemuan revolusioner yang
dibuat tapi itu bukan fokus dari kursus ini, sebagai gantinya aku ingin memperjelas bahwa kita tahu bahwa mekanika
kuantum dan komputasi sudah kompatibel satu sama lain, temuan dan pemahaman tentang alam
yang kita pelajari dari mekanika kuantum sebagian telah membuat komputer modern kita menjadi mungkin, tanpa mekanika
kuantum kita tidak akan memahami atau mungkin bahkan tidak bisa menemukan solid state hard drive
misalnya, komputasi Quantum adalah langkah alami berikutnya dalam Evolusi ini
tapi komputasi tidak hanya ada di ruang hampa, informasi memerlukan medium
memproses informasi memanfaatkan dunia fisik dan itu mempengaruhinya juga, ini menempatkan batasan pada apa yang bahkan secara fisik
mungkin tapi memahami alam dan batasan fisik sebenarnya adalah tujuan fisika sebagai
disiplin ilmu, jadi dalam satu cara fisika dan komputasi selalu saling terkait, Ralph Landauer, ilmuwan komputer dan IBMer
menyadari beberapa dekade lalu bahwa informasi itu bersifat fisik, dengan kata lain informasi bukan
entitas abstrak tetapi hanya ada melalui representasi fisik, prinsip Landauer menetapkan hubungan
antara informasi dan hukum termodinamika tapi sebenarnya ada banyak hubungan antara fisika dan
komputasi, fisika klasik adalah semua yang bisa kita jelajahi sampai baru-baru ini tapi dengan penemuan mekanika
kuantum kita sekarang berada di ambang kemampuan untuk menciptakan cara yang sepenuhnya baru untuk menghitung dan ini bagus karena
komputer klasik hanya bisa mengaproksimasi apa yang sebenarnya terjadi di alam dan dalam beberapa kasus aproksimasi itu sangat
terbatas, itu karena sungguh sangat sulit untuk mendapatkan mesin yang mengikuti hukum fisika klasik untuk
mengaproksimasi hukum fisika kuantum dan alam itu bukan klasik, alam itu kuantum, satu analogi yang mungkin membantu kamu
memahami adalah wind tunnel, dinamika fluida terkenal sulit untuk disimulasikan dan diprediksi secara matematis
bahkan sesuatu yang biasa seperti mobil yang melaju melalui angin, produsen mobil menemukan bahwa sebenarnya
terlalu mahal dan tidak praktis untuk mencoba mensimulasikan interaksi fisik ini ketika mereka merancang mobil, sebagai gantinya apa
yang akhirnya mereka lakukan adalah membuat terowongan harfiah yang meniupkan angin melaluinya dan hanya mengemudikan mobil ke dalam terowongan
dan melihat bagaimana kinerjanya, ini analogis dengan apa yang aku maksud ketika aku bilang komputer klasik hanya secara buruk
mengaproksimasi alam dan terkadang terlalu mahal bahkan untuk mencoba membuatnya melakukannya, alih-alih mensimulasikan angin
para peneliti hanya menciptakannya kembali, demikian pula komputer kuantum tidak harus mengaproksimasi hukum alam pada
tingkat molekuler karena mereka mengikuti hukum-hukum tersebut secara intrinsik, mereka tidak harus mensimulasikan apa pun, mereka mengemulasikannya dan
kesulitan yang sama muncul ketika kita mensimulasikan baterai atau reaksi kimia yang membawa kita ke bagian
berikutnya, Quantum Computing apa kegunaannya? jadi
mengapa kita bahkan ingin memikirkan untuk menggabungkan mekanika kuantum dan komputasi? well sudah ada banyak
masalah yang terlalu sulit, terlalu mahal secara komputasi bahkan untuk superkomputer mutakhir kita untuk diselesaikan
mungkin ini adalah masalah yang hanya para peneliti yang sangat fokus tapi dampaknya bisa menyentuh semua bagian dari
dunia, masalah-masalah yang membuat komputer klasik macet adalah hal-hal yang kita sebagai masyarakat semakin mengandalkan teknologi
dan benar-benar peduli seperti efisiensi baterai, pemodelan keuangan dan
optimasi dan bahkan bagaimana membangun pesawat yang lebih baik, jadi mengapa beralih ke komputer kuantum? well kita punya alasan yang sangat baik
untuk berpikir ada banyak potensi di sini dan kita bisa membuka pintu ke komputasi baru yang saat ini Di Luar Jangkauan bahkan untuk
superkomputer paling kuat sekalipun, secara teori beberapa algoritma Quantum memberikan keunggulan dibandingkan
algoritma klasik terbaik yang mungkin untuk beberapa aplikasi, untuk aplikasi lain ada bukti yang semakin banyak bahwa bahkan
dengan beberapa noise dan ketidaksempurnaan komputer kuantum masih bisa digunakan sebagai alat untuk bersaing dengan solusi klasik brute
force, pada dasarnya ini adalah alat yang sepenuhnya baru dan kita ingin mencari tahu hal-hal lebih keren yang bisa kita lakukan dengannya tapi kita juga bisa
kembali ke ide asli Feynman untuk mereka yaitu menggunakannya untuk memahami fisika dan alam itu sendiri
lagipula aku sudah memberi tahu kamu bahwa alam itu kuantum bukan klasik dan bidang ini sangat kaya menarik dan
interdisipliner, ini menyatukan fisika, ilmu komputer, pemrosesan informasi dan tentu saja domain spesifik dari area aplikasi yang
mungkin kita minati, namun tidak seperti komputer klasik tidak semua orang memiliki komputer kuantum yang tersimpan di saku belakang mereka
sampai sangat baru-baru ini, kalau kamu ingin bereksperimen dengan komputer kuantum kamu harus membangun dan memelihara
sendiri biasanya di lab basement yang menyedihkan di universitas atau fasilitas penelitian dan percayalah aku tahu, tidak lagi
demikian halnya, namun pada tahun 2016 IBM menempatkan prosesor Quantum pertama di cloud, saat itu hanya memiliki lima qubit dan
tingkat error yang cukup tinggi tapi itu hanya 8 tahun yang lalu dan lihat seberapa jauh kita sudah datang, jadi di mana kita berdiri hari ini?
ada banyak paralel yang bisa ditarik ke hari-hari sangat awal dari komputer modern, seperti yang aku sebutkan ini adalah tantangan yang sangat
sulit dan baru dalam 8 tahun terakhir komputer kuantum menjadi tersedia secara luas kecuali bagi
mereka yang bekerja di lab atau fasilitas terdepan tapi dalam delapan tahun terakhir itu kita telah membuat kemajuan di setiap
WEBVTT
bidang, prosesor bertambah besar dalam ukuran qubit secara berlipat ganda, gate jauh lebih baik dan kita telah memperkenalkan metode
untuk mengurangi atau memitigasi error yang intrinsik pada sistem kuantum bahkan sementara kita terus maju untuk membuat komputer
kuantum yang toleran terhadap kesalahan, sekarang kamu dan siapa pun lainnya bisa menggunakan salah satu dari berbagai prosesor IBM Quantum yang
di-host di cloud hampir semuanya adalah sistem terbaru, terkini dan terbaik dengan lebih dari 100
qubit, tapi bukan hanya ukuran prosesor yang penting, ini hanya satu metrik yang kita perhatikan dan
itu masuk akal kan kalau kita punya lebih banyak qubit, itu jelas lebih baik dengan syarat bahwa menambah jumlah qubit
tidak menurunkan performa, namun ini tidak selalu demikian, kita perlu lebih banyak qubit berkualitas baik yang tidak saling mengganggu
satu sama lain melalui cross talk ketika kita tidak menginginkannya, bagaimana qubit terhubung satu sama lain juga merupakan sesuatu yang penting untuk diingat dalam
circuit superkonduktor, ini adalah tantangan untuk mencari tahu cara terbaik menghubungkan qubit secara fisik, metrik lain yang sangat penting
adalah fidelity gate dua qubit, gate yang berjalan pada qubit tunggal tidak begitu rentan terhadap error, gate dua qubit adalah area
perhatian yang jauh lebih besar dan biasanya salah satu metrik andalan yang kita cari untuk melihat bagaimana performa berkembang dari waktu ke
waktu, gate dua qubit sangat penting untuk dilakukan dengan benar karena mereka bertanggung jawab untuk menciptakan entanglement antara qubit
yang merupakan salah satu fenomena fisika yang memberikan komputer kuantum kekuatannya, terakhir kita mencari kecepatan dan efisiensi
kita perlu memastikan bahwa waktu yang dihabiskan untuk menjalankan program pada chip kuantum dieksekusi secepat dan seefisien
mungkin, kita menyebut ketiga metrik ini bersama-sama sebagai scale quality dan
speed, semuanya vital untuk meningkatkan performa, sekarang aku ingin menunjukkan beberapa plot cepat untuk mendukung apa yang aku telah
katakan tentang bagaimana teknologi itu sendiri benar-benar berkembang dengan cukup pesat, jumlah qubit itu sendiri adalah yang paling mudah untuk
dipahami menurutku dan IBM telah menerbitkan roadmap tentang di mana kita berharap berada dalam beberapa tahun ke depan dalam hal jumlah qubit
dan ukuran prosesor, untuk 2024 ketika kita merekam video ini kita tepat pada jadwal dengan prosesor Heron dan Condor, berikutnya
adalah kualitas, plot ini menunjukkan median entangling gate error rate untuk prosesor IBM Quantum dari waktu ke waktu, perlu diingat
bahwa ini adalah skala log sehingga meskipun kemajuannya terlihat agak linear sebenarnya jauh lebih pesat dari itu
terakhir kita punya kecepatan, grafik ini menunjukkan kemajuan dari metrik yang kita sebut CLOPS yang merupakan singkatan dari circuit layer
operations per second, secara penting CLOPS mencakup baik waktu yang dibutuhkan untuk menjalankan circuit maupun komputasi klasik real dan
near-time yang diperlukan, pada dasarnya CLOPS adalah ukuran seberapa cepat prosesor kita bisa menjalankan circuit tertentu dalam
rangkaian yang bertindak sebagai ukuran kecepatan sistem holistik dan menggabungkan komputasi Quantum dan
klasik, saat ini pada saat perekaman IBM adalah satu-satunya penyedia cloud Quantum yang menyediakan akses ke mesin 100 plus
qubit seperti yang aku sebutkan beberapa slide yang lalu, 100 qubit atau sekitar sana adalah di mana simulasi klasik
mulai gagal total jadi pekerjaan berskala besar yang dijalankan pada mesin-mesin ini sering tidak memiliki ekuivalen klasik, itu tidak
mungkin, ada beberapa nuansa dan beberapa tips dan trik yang bisa kamu mainkan untuk mensimulasikan beberapa bagian dari circuit dan kemudian bagian lain
secara terpisah tapi secara umum kita tahu bahwa sekitar angka ini adalah di mana komputer kuantum bisa mulai melakukan hal-hal yang tidak bisa dilakukan komputer klasik, jadi
IBM memutuskan bahwa memberikan akses ke perangkat yang lebih besar ini sangat penting untuk komunitas yang lebih luas karena apa pun
yang dilakukan pada perangkat yang lebih kecil bisa disimulasikan secara klasik sehingga tidak bisa mengarah ke Quantum Advantage, perangkat 100 qubit
yang kita miliki sekarang masih memiliki kekurangan dan masih noisy jadi kita perlu pintar tentang cara kita menjalankan pekerjaan dan
circuit pada mereka, secara naif hanya menulis circuit kita dan menekan shift enter mungkin tidak akan menghasilkan apa pun
yang spektakuler tapi sekali lagi ada tips dan trik yang bisa kita implementasikan dan praktik terbaik yang bisa kita ikuti untuk memeras lebih banyak lagi
performa dari perangkat-perangkat ini yang semoga mengarah ke Quantum Advantage lebih cepat bahkan sementara kita terus
bekerja dan membangun mesin toleran terhadap kesalahan kita juga, plot ini menunjukkan biaya simulasi
atau jumlah waktu yang dibutuhkan untuk menyelesaikan masalah pada komputer klasik dan komputer kuantum yang dilengkapi dengan error
mitigation dan error correction, jadi garis komputasi klasik skalanya secara eksponensial seiring kompleksitas circuit
bertumbuh, untuk circuit sederhana di sini itu tidak masalah tapi jelas buruk seiring kompleksitas bertumbuh karena ini
membuat biaya simulasi sangat mahal dengan sangat cepat, error mitigation skalanya lebih baik jadi ketika kompleksitas
circuit bertumbuh di situlah kita ingin berada, kita saat ini berada di sini dengan metode klasik dan metode Quantum yang kurang lebih
setara satu sama lain untuk beberapa aplikasi dan error correction mungkin yang paling disukai dan skalanya
sangat bagus, kita hanya belum sampai di sana, sementara itu kita akan terus berfokus pada error mitigation dan sampai ke area
quantum utility sesegera mungkin dan dengan memanfaatkan beberapa skema error mitigation yang akan
kita pelajari dalam seri ini kita bertujuan untuk menemukan area aplikasi yang bisa memanfaatkan quantum utility sangat segera dan itulah
yang benar-benar menjadi inti dari kursus ini, kita memiliki mesin-mesin ini dan kita pikir mereka mampu melakukan beberapa
penelitian yang benar-benar menarik, jadi bagaimana kita menggunakannya? dalam bagian terakhir episode ini mari kita bahas secara singkat area aplikasi untuk
Quantum Computing praktis, ada tiga cabang utama yang menurut kita paling antusias kita jelajahi dan temukan jalan untuk Quantum
utility, yang pertama adalah mensimulasikan alam, ini berkaitan dengan mensimulasikan interaksi molekuler atau atom dan ini
benar-benar penting untuk bidang material science dan kimia dan karena alasan yang kita bahas sebelumnya kita pikir komputer
kuantum akan jauh lebih baik dalam hal ini daripada pendamping komputer klasiknya, berikutnya adalah pencarian dan
optimasi, algoritma utama yang diminati di sini disebut qaoa, sebuah algoritma hybrid klasik-Quantum, qaoa menggunakan
komputer klasik untuk melatih dan menemukan parameter optimal untuk Quantum circuit dan kita semoga bisa melakukan ini dengan
jauh lebih efisien daripada yang bisa dilakukan komputer mana pun sendirian, terakhir kita punya matematika dan memproses data dengan struktur, komputer
kuantum sangat bagus dalam menemukan struktur dalam data yang berantakan di mana kamu atau aku atau komputer biasa mungkin tidak melihat
apa pun, Quantum machine learning menjanjikan di area ini dan kita bertujuan menggunakannya untuk tugas-tugas seperti feature
extraction dan pengenalan pola, ini benar-benar waktu yang sangat menarik bagi kita yang bekerja di
bidang Quantum Computing, untuk pertama kalinya dalam sejarah kita bisa mulai menjelajahi wilayah komputasi yang melampaui
komputasi klasik, mereka yang menonton ini mungkin memainkan peran serupa dengan para pionir awal
komputasi dan mereka tidak memiliki konsepsi tentang apa yang akan mengikuti, T J Watson dari IBM bahkan dengan terkenal mengatakan dia pikir ada
WEBVTT
mungkin pasar untuk hanya dua atau tiga komputer saja dan wow, betapa salahnya dia, kita
semua adalah para pionir awal komputasi itu tapi dalam bidang baru Quantum Computing ini dan Quantum sering
dikontraskan dengan komputasi klasik sebagai sesuatu yang berbeda secara berbeda darinya dan sering dalam persaingan dengannya tapi tujuan
aku untuk kuliah pengantar ini adalah semoga meyakinkan kamu bahwa dari sudut pandang yang luas kita bisa melihat Quantum
Computing sebagai sekadar bab berikutnya dalam kisah panjang komputasi, ini adalah sifat kita sebagai manusia untuk mencari cara baru untuk
menghitung dan untuk memanfaatkan kekuatan dunia alam dan untuk mencari tahu apa yang harus dilakukan dengannya dan kita telah melakukan ini selama
berabad-abad, Quantum Computing menawarkan kita alat baru dalam usaha ini dan terserah kita untuk menemukan bagaimana kita bisa memanfaatkan
kekuatan yang ditawarkannya, dalam pelajaran berikutnya dalam seri ini kita akan membahas sedikit lebih banyak tentang sistem 100 qubit
dan memberikan gambaran umum tentang Qiskit, SDK perangkat lunak qu kita dan cara terbaik berinteraksi dengan mesin-mesin ini saat ini, terima kasih telah
menonton dan sampai jumpa lain waktu